discover a ターン24時間せいかターン
ああああああ
me
なんだなぁお兄ちゃんのジムそうですというわけでこちらに見えますさあ皆さんよく
救う場面ある思いますエスカレーターでございますエスカレーター何がと言います
階段が登りより大変な時とか長いと言うの時に乗ってるだけで自動で動く
エスカレーターなんですけどもいい動く
no 6ないですか0に動くもんで私と魅力を感じてしまいましてお店ではやっちゃ
ダメなんですけど逆走をしてる東亜のハムスターみたいな ai に動き続けることに
なるんですけどねぇどうなるかなと思いまして今日は24時間やってみたいと思います
ただもう当たってる通り多分松任24時間やろうと思うと無理なくて3時間に1回
サイコロを振って出た目に応じでご褒美がもらえますというの
6パターン示しました思いますね数字
違うと思えば1
僕とであ後輩と交代ということで僕らしいんですよ
あの一瞬灯台なんでこれじゃなくても1ジャンキーみたいなところありますとりあえず
a に誰かが乗ってることが今回の使命
1時間のみー
なっていた
3ななし4
何ん
ていません
ますしますどこまでがエスカデだかって話があると思うんですけども
エスカレーター横に動くともですけどもこれこれ9エスカデータだと思うんですよ
ただもちろんここでたずっと待ってるともうそれをとかじゃないと思うので普段
微笑骨にますあの階段の部分いるんでその芽が出る時はここに入れるという感じです
おおーー
なるほどですね筋肉的には楽になる場面があるのかもしれないです6
財布
l 時間2日
りんかいエスカレーターウォッチ続ける人の何いつかレイター
で生活することで今回の曲の木刀無難で止まっていても私はここにいれば企画どこでも
でロックで一番俺はお気がします
3時間に1回この日かがべきでサイコロ送らせていただきますよね
だけどしますたくさん1使う場所出るとも他のお客さんの迷惑になります
タイまで市内よりお願いします今回は特別にあるせていただいておりますでは
[音楽]
さあ12時なったらスタート男に1分でしたおしまい
んでのルールとしては一緒に中ですでも飲んでもいいした人もいいです
野党と入れないでください以上ず0
ぼよんさんに
1いっさあ
[音楽]
ああああああああ
me
これいく性質です
よってノレ
ええええええええええええええええ
持った
あっても見て最初はまたぁ買いたくなくなり
ございますここでずっと
いるのもありだした
バッハ
me me
voodoo これによってよ
goo
ああああああ
おっん
[音楽]
[拍手]
うわああああ
[音楽]
hey
me
dj 1時間25分
僕はんだけど
奥まで見ているらしい
めっちゃ4まだでしょ
これねわれ
もうありがとうございます絶対屋さんからも動きませんちょっと難症例からやろうと
思えばやれへ
これ8
合意うううううっ
[音楽]
pale
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
web とろーっ
[音楽]
身近ああ
むううう9章イヤー
同じにバケツ
wh
ani
ああああああ
工夫しない
dare ni
me
思いません
はい一応
yeah
wh
いますん
結構暗い一番です
じゃあ
へいへい
[音楽]
4強いろんな
クレヨンですねー
dji 医院 te 2
1 re 1
はそこで
疲れてるぞん
jr 2
はぁ
んん
盲孔からでも積極座ってルってまだ家に vista でます
冬アニメ
座ってるとヤバイ
ございます
まだ
はいはい
地上で家でもたーっっ
hi hoo
[音楽]
ああああああああ
dare
goo 2
[音楽]
dare
ni
[音楽]
ああああああ
普通ん
ええええええ
re re
お渡して
凍って生き返った
被弾したいやー次の財布次第ではちょっと入りにくい困るじゃないだろ結構
うううう
お願いしまーす
公平にゃろわー
6時間
ん
もうああああ
tai
wh
[音楽]
運営
末ん
ああああああ
wh
いいいい
amaran
1は1時間 a はい
ani
nao cha
どうよ2
床がといった
[拍手]
yeah yeah
彼にもにが来た時俺ちょっと京川がないだよちょっと
味わってもらいますだから月経
持っていますいいえ
動いてれば空気にならないんですとこの休憩を本当に存分に活かしたい
ありません
ああああああああ
これはん
小松で時間
ああああああ
桜まんじゅうちょっと刑事がマンガと上げてみた感じ一度マジで無理っぽいンって10
分で付く
まず10分です g ボールを一定ですよ20分でマーシー言ってる
いや新通すみませんね
10分で10分か真ん中の3まぁ簡単に言うと回だー10分がすごいそこで残り続ける
っていう行為なぁでマジでやばいと思います
これ
me
io
ん
ああああああ
するぜ
who 進んでません
goo
ん
wh
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおん
ああああああ
4 a
[音楽]
goo
rar
detarame
安全なロゼ
ん
おっ
me
09:00 rar
今ここにっ
持っていたはい
jr
ああああああああ
8よ
star
第一ねっ
ああああああいうええん
[音楽]
ええええ
car
[拍手]
teal
さあん
えってねー
em
伝わりますません epa が実父がそれの位置でございましたね
[音楽]
ああああああ
ni
[音楽]
はい
rar
壮大ルームです
ni
駄文
me
いいいいいいいん
ana
大味軍艦大和とりあえず1時までです
ゆけゆけ
[音楽]
ni
voodoo
none
ええええええ
西が6件
なのでちょっと普通じゃん
pas
[音楽]
皆さん0なぜか w
lai e 6 e
妻で死ねる
[音楽]
ん
ああああああああ
いますえっ
[音楽]
tan
ああああああ
ran
[音楽]
ua
6連単で財布絶対数かける時間維持くれるぞ
hey
豊富でこれでどんなで恋人止めるかで俺じゃねーけど
ありがとうございます
ギャーじゃあ
[音楽]
まあへああああああ
6時間休みたかったねーまさかの1-
ok 6出せばいいから確か中継します
1時間が週年前
[音楽]
ん
知事を入れました
[音楽]
got to do たあああ
こっちいいん
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
う
heno
のげーろろん
[音楽]
しましたこれ
んふっつーの
[音楽]
はいに精時間きました資格取った
ございますとっくに限界です強いくださいですよね
の最後対するあるそこで謎を引いてるこれも縁リースで車
面白いと思います
[音楽]
何かあっはぁこれええええええ
残り3時間を知っていると思います
はぁ
[音楽]
もううわぁ
えっとリーダー逆いいんです
21時間頑張ってください
これ一発本当にパシロスしちゃいませんね
そういうふうに全開でフレーズはたかみーちゃんえっ
はい me
[音楽]
なぜ学生のみん
ああああああ
はぁはぁん
andare
rar
いるじゃあさあ
[音楽]
can you do
こうする時の方が来づらいです変なことをな口から打って上げてあるのポストは
しっかり立ててる
ンドレーダーっ
ka 勝負し持っ
がとうございまーすございます
goo yeah
ああああああああ
ありません
現在がというとずっと同じ場所意識を持ってから
製紙メーカー月から普通酒飲んで酔っぱらって逆走スツールだけど3インチません姫役
の動画に入った黒の誰だ
コードはすべて絶対マネしないと思っています
本当に一つ目はから手話はないんだよ
私は自己責任風景
25歳の2人24時間すると安全確保にも本でいただいておりました
絶対にマネしないと
ています
dj
入っていんを
[音楽]
o 4ターン
いい
1位
her ear ん
周泳
me
ni
[音楽]
rear
car
me
なんでこんなことしたいや今回の動画でいつかネーターっての生活は
難しいていることがございました是非産後に
[音楽]
blh pa
エスカレーター24時間を使わせていただいた希少だけをさせていただきました
急遽さんに
撮影距離をいただきます本当に
客層せるかも迫ったがずっとしたくさんを張ってて申し訳ないです
ん